this uh story struck me uh personally
because it has to do with steven
spielberg
some oscar controversy is heating up
around town deadline reports that the
oscars is cutting eight categories from
the telecast and steven spielberg is
saying he hopes they'll change their
mind the academy plans to leave out
several short film categories plus
production design which we are literally
just talking about how important it is
original score music can change the
whole way you feel about a scene you're
watching film editing which is a
complete art in itself you choose the
takes from the actors you choose what
pieces of the story to leave in and out
oh and makeup and hair styling
what what yeah i know
they will give these awards out before
the show and edit their acceptance
speeches into the live telecast
um spielberg and a chorus of critics are
saying these categories deserve to share
the stage alongside of them and stephen
has been quoted saying there is no above
the line and below the line which means
you know stars and crew i totally agree
with him steven has also said he is a
complete fan of the president of the
academy this is also a network decision
and i think they're just trying to find
a way to
keep the pace alive but at what cost
exactly we can't forget that movie
making is such a collaborative process
as a fan i want to see the people who
make the movies
being celebrated that's the whole point
you have to put on a good show but you
can't lose focus yeah
all right next up you know if there is a
little leap that you're thinking of
taking in your life no matter how big or
small maybe this story will inspire you
to just go for it the week reports it's
about to be a huge homecoming for tom
tersich on april 2nd 2015 a day before
he turned 26 tom left his new jersey
home with one goal to travel the entire
world on foot
yeah since then he's traveled over 25
000 miles most of it with savannah right
here a dog that he adopted on a stop in
texas oh savannah and now tom has burned
through 45 pairs of sneakers traveling
through the mountains of kurdistan
following a flock of sheep in iceland
kayaking through antarctica he was
inspired to take this journey when he
was just 17 years old because he lost a
young friend and he realized that he
wanted to make the most of the time we
all have on this earth and now i mean
this story
now believe this or not
now he is on day
1789 of his journey he's just weeks away
from making it home
walking around the entire world what
and i just hope that he brought his
fitbit because can you imagine at the
end oh man
i i this story
it speaks to me so much that we have
these choices in life
and i have so much respect and
admiration for his choices
[Music]